Привет! В прошлом уроке мы собрали экраны продукта. Они выглядят так же, как в макете,
но пока статичны. Кнопки не нажимаются, переходов нет, формы ничего не делают. Между экранами не
походить, не проверить, как это всё работает. Сегодня мы это исправим, оживим наш прототип,
подключим поведение и из набора экранов получится у нас рабочее приложение, по которому можно ходить,
как по-настоящему продукту. И прежде чем мы это сделаем, давай разберёмся, чем это вообще отличается
от кликабельного прототипа Figma. Figma прототип — это такие как бы нарисованные сомнительные переходы:
ты связал экраны стрелками, по клику один сменяется другим, путь зафиксирован, данных нет, логики
нет, там верификации каких-то состояний тоже особо нет. Это показ задумки на одном, скорее всего,
ровном сценарии. Какие-то U-тесты ты, конечно, можешь посмотреть, насколько вообще прозрачна там
навигация, насколько понятен float для человека, но глубокого тестирования ты тут, конечно,
не проведёшь. Обычно для этого уже в коде собирают версию, дропают на тесты и там уже смотрят,
там уже можно собрать реальные нормальные метрики. Мы же пропустим этот этап нерабочего прототипа и
будем отрабатывать сразу настоящее поведение. Навигация работает, форма принимает ввод, что-то с ним
делает, данные меняются. Создал, например, сервер, в моём случае, и он там в списке у тебя появился.
Также все состояния по действию, какие-то всплывающие уведомления и так далее. То есть проработка
edge cases. Их сложно предусмотреть в прототипировании. Здесь же агент сам на себя всё это забирает,
это предусмотрено в директиве, который мы будем использовать. Нас это лишает большой головной боли.
Ведь вручную всё это отрисовать – это, блин, огромное количество времени. Поэтому такой прототип – это, ну, прямо
предпродукт и его можно уже тестировать всерьёз. Твоей задачей при этом будет докинуть к вызову директивы,
возможно, какие-то те вещи, которые ты уже сейчас видишь, что нужно точно предусмотреть, ну,
либо полагаться на него и в конечном итоге пройти flow, посмотреть, как это действительно работает и дать
ему правки. Думаю, это не сложно. На этот раз директива называется wire. Точно так же её перетаскиваем,
как обычно, и запускаем. И в прошлом уроке говорил, но ещё раз отмечу, когда у тебя будут появляться новые
экраны, ты можешь отдельно вызывать эту директиву. Ну, желательно с упоминанием того, что у меня появились
новые экраны. Я хочу проверить, насколько всё взаимосвязано, насколько всё это дело работает.
Поэтому пройдись ещё раз. Если сделать это без упоминания конкретной директивы, то он, ну,
сделает это как-то по-своему. Возможно, и не вспомнит, что у него для этого уже предписаны все шаги.
Поэтому упоминаем директиву, даём задачу. Итак, агент закончил работу. Давай посмотрим,
что у нас тут получилось. Ну, например, что? Создать сервер Debian, Alma Linux. Да, здесь применяется всё это.
Тут вообще эту штуку можно, конечно, зафиксировать, сделать стики. Агента об этом попрошу.
Выбираем регион. Также у нас тут всё меняется. Цена, влияние на прогноз, насколько нам хватит денег,
имя сервера и так далее. Всё это можно поменять. Нажимаем создать. Сервер создаётся, появляется уведомление.
Сервер готов. После небольшого дилея. Он сам это предусмотрел, чтобы подобно выглядело.
Вот. Появился ещё один сервер. Теперь их четыре. Смотрим также, как это выглядит.
Когда у нас уже не три в ряд аккуратно бьётся, а появляется четвёртый.
То есть мы тут уже можем предусмотреть, либо вот так он будет, либо он тут в грид будет ложиться,
либо растягиваться на всю ширину. Ну, пускай, например, тут на всю ширину.
Хочу его удалить. Также 3точие уже предусматривает это взаимодействие. Можно его перезагрузить.
Также у нас тут варианты. Перезагрузка. Перезагрузка запущена.
Также всплывают уведомления. Ну и давай его удалим.
Чтобы его удалить, нужно вписать его имя, этого сервера, как это обычно бывает.
Иначе ничего сделать нельзя. Хотим вернуться, можем нажать.
Скопируем название его. Пять, четыре, три - никак. Это не работает.
Вводим ровно то значение, которое нужно. Название сервера удалить навсегда.
Всё. Сервер удалился. Всплывающее уведомление о том, что там ещё 13 USD вернулось на баланс.
Детали. Также тут у нас всё. Здесь можно ещё добавить, чтобы анимация была.
Прогрузки этих графиков. Перезагрузить. Смена. Остановить.
Сервер установлен. Статус сменился. Вот.
Ну, у меня здесь всего три экрана, поэтому тут как бы сильно не разгуляешься.
Но, да.
Видно уже, что всё у нас здесь работает.
Дальше остаётся только точечно. Здесь указать на правки, сказать ему, что он там не предусмотрел, не сделал, вот, например, поведение при копировании этого айпишника.
Он здесь не обратил внимание на то, что это нужно сделать.
Так же тут у нас по выравниванию надо, чтобы автоотступ был.
Короче, такие точечные мелкие правки.
Можно прям скринами ему отправлять с описанием того, что хочется поменять.
Мы собрали прототип. Он рабочий. Его можно дополнять. У нас есть все соответствующие для этого директивы.
Точечно можем указывать, что нужно поменять. Нам остаётся только его доработать.
Но всё, что мы сейчас сделали, это хранится у нас локально.
И если ты будешь проводить Q-тест с этим всем, то тебе придётся самому сидеть и наблюдать, как у пользователя это дело работает.
Либо делать скринкаст и потом всё это разбирать. Это не очень удобно.
Ну и в целом, как это перекинуть, должна быть какая-то ссылка, по которой можно перейти, потыкать, посмотреть.
Всем этим мы займёмся в следующих уроках.
Ну а пока домашнее задание. После предыдущего урока у тебя уже как минимум один есть экран.
Ну, я думаю, что все будут делать хотя бы по три тех, что уже готовы в фигме.
Собираем их, оживляем с той директивы, которую я сегодня использовал.
Точно так же допиливаем точечно мелкими правками.
И для сдачи домашней работы ты можешь либо прикреплять скрины, в которых видно, что там сменяются состояния.
Достаточно будет скрина 3, либо в идеале вообще сделать запись экрана, залить куда-нибудь себе на Яндекс.Диск, на Мейл.Диск, на Гугл.Диск и так далее.
И скинуть ссылку. Обязательно проследи, чтобы доступ был открыт по этой ссылке.
На этом всё. Удачи с выполнением домашнего задания и увидимся в следующем уроке.